808 et qui rendent ans issus de neuf
nationalités se sont retrouvés du 1er au
4 août dernier au haras des bréviaires
pour la 52e édition de l'est qui rendent
aux quatre mois après l'heure est au
bilan
au delà même de ses trois jours haras
des bréviaires
les cavaliers leurs familles ont
sillonné des kilomètres et des
kilomètres de territoires c'est le cas
dans les forêts domaniales mais
également à travers les plaines
ça a permis d'animer les yvelines est en
tout cas ce sud yvelines à cette période
de l'année
un succès populaire pour ce plus gros
rassemblement européen de tourisme
équestre
douze mille personnes ont assisté le 3
août au défilé dans les rues de
rambouillet le point d'orgue de la
manifestation un bilan positif également
au niveau économique
cent soixante mille euros ont été
injectés dans le territoire sud yvelines
l événement a notamment dopé le tourisme
très belle vitrine pour le département
pour prennent pour protéger et puis pour
promouvoir cette ruralité et ce tourisme
local et surtout le terrible casting il
ya déjà une trentaine de gîtes qui ont
été inscrits par la société ic i move
dans des gîtes qui permettent
d'accueillir des personnes mais aussi
des chevaux ce qu'ils vont développer le
tourisme local sur le sud yvelines
premier département équestre de france
par son nombre de licenciés et les
yvelines compte bien profiter du
dynamisme créés par l'événement pour les
jeux olympiques en 2024
le haras des bréviaires pourrait être un
lieu de référence